das hier ist übrigens das t shirt an die
die sich nicht erinnern können also hier
habe ich dir das shirt ich hoffe du
kannst damit was anfangen würde es
einfach mal geben und das interessante
ist jetzt wir haben einmal einen neuen
xbox one controller und leute ganz kurz
unterbrechung und zwar eine sache auf
dem kopf wie youtube kanal gibt es
wieder ein neues video von mir und zwar
war ich unterwegs mit dem alois im
europa park in rust jemanden ganz kurzer
ausschnitt vom video
und ich kann euch eins sagen das video
lohnt sich wirklich anzuschauen das ist
ganz normal wieder beschreibung verlinkt
wir hatten ein megacoolen tag das wetter
war gut das hat eine menge spaß gemacht
die ganze nacht waren sofern wasser
waren zu fahren und sehr gerne
vorbeischauen
wie gesagt in der beschreibung verlegt
und jetzt geht es hier weiter hey leute
was geht ab und herzlich willkommen bei
einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut ich freue mich
wirklich sehr auf dieses video weil
heute steht endlich der dritte part von
büroklammer zum iphone hoch tauschen an
also ich hoffe es klappt doch alles so
wie es mir vorgestellt hab' ich habe ja
letztens ein video hochgeladen habe ich
so eine ankündigung dazu gemacht also
wie es mit dem thema weitergeht
und das ist halt sehr sehr schwer ist
einfach auf die straße zu gehen und sich
hoch zu tauschen und dann wirklich
erfolg zu haben also wenn es um kleine
gegenstände geht ist das gar kein
problem aber wenn man dann auch irgend
etwas vernünftiges haben will wie zum
beispiel in meinem fall ja das handy
also ich habe mir als ziel gesetzt
irgendwann mal dein iphone zu bekommen
und dann bin ich auf die idee gekommen
einfach euch zu fragen mich immer mit
jemandem von euch zu treffen und
irgendwas zu tauschen und darum geht es
heute nachdem ich das video hochgeladen
habe habe ich wirklich extrem viele
nachrichten bekommen auf install
förmlich kann ich das gern mal kurz
zeigen wir nehmen wir hier kurz dem
bildschirm auf ich treffe mich um 16 uhr
mit dem farbige hier habe ich das auch
schon alles abgeklärt ja bla bla bla was
er mir tauschen jetzt sage ich euch
jetzt besser noch nicht kleine
überraschungen so ich zeige euch mal
kurz was die ganzen leute geschrieben
haben würde gegen jb l kopfhörer das t
shirt tauschen ja alex ich würde meine
beats kopfhörer tauschen würde mich über
eine kurze antwort freuen ich kann auch
ein samsung galaxy s3 mini tauschen
instruktion schüler kommen aus
düsseldorf oder mein altes iphone 5 also
das haben wir wirklich auch sehr viele
leute geschrieben
jo alex wenn du willst du kannst mir ein
altes iphone haben das ding ist das
wollte ich nicht so gerne machen ich
will immer vertauschen dass wir einfach
noch viel zu weit oben auch wenn das
heute machen würden leute ganz kurz noch
und zwar mir ist ein fehler unterlaufen
ich bin davon ausgegangen dass die
person mit der ich mich treffe fabian
heißt weil in ihrer er in ihrer
instagram bio stand einfach drin
fabi und das profil bei privat keine
ahnung ich hab damit direkt fabian
verknüpft und habe dann immer gesagt ja
ich treffe mich heute mit dem fabia bei
sehen ob der korrekt ist und so weiter
deswegen also sorry wenn du das siehst
ja keine ahnung wusste ich nicht ich
hoffe du nimmst es mir nicht übel fabian
schöne grüße noch mal und jetzt machen
wir weiter
und seid gespannt was ich bekomme jetzt
leute und falsche die ersten beiden
folgen hiervon noch nicht gesehen habe
die sind ganz oben in der videos
verlinkt schaut euch auf
verlässt die an weil dann noch dieses
video auch viel mehr sind und ihr
versteht was es eigentlich geht
wir treffen uns jetzt mit dem fabian ich
würde sagen ihr kommt natürlich mit und
ja mal sehen ob der fabian korrekt ist
ich bin gespannt
wir fahren jetzt los ich treffe mich
hier in köln am bahnhof deutz mit ihm
aber ich muss leider erstmal noch kurz
meine sachen zusammenpacken weil ich
danach direkt zu meinen eltern nach
hause fahre also jetzt heißt es erst mal
packen
das hier ist übrigens das t shirt an die
die sich nicht erinnern können ja
vielleicht irgendwas hat was dagegen
wenn diese handy halle tauschen würde
die leute werden es gerade geklärt dass
wir einen scherz vielleicht bekommen
aber er guckt man nach darf man fragen
was so etwas kostet
danke megacool leute lieber ist toll
geht hierhin von levi's mit justin
timberlake in kooperation komplett neuen
größe m und dass wir das heute getauscht
wir fahren jetzt tun
[Applaus]
leute wir sind jetzt hier am bahnhof das
problem ist das megaphon und leider ist
das profil familien privat also ich habe
keine ahnung wie er aussieht deswegen
versuche ich ihn jetzt gerade hier
ich hoffe mal das klappt jetzt gleich
auch also lasst einfach und die kamera
laufen vielleicht kommt hier gleich
jemand die polizei gleich kriegen wir
noch einen hier sind so ein knöllchen
ran ans auto das man das mal raus
[Musik]
von welcher seite kommt jetzt jemand
zwölf sekunden später
blockieren
also das ist fabian und wir haben uns
connected trat voll witz ich habe sowas
selbst noch nicht gemacht was ich schon
mal einem youtube video ja
wahrscheinlich weil wir den unterlagen
auch echt also hier habe ich dir das
shirt ich hoffe du kannst damit was
anfangen für das einfach mal geben und
das interessante ist jetzt das
interessante ist jetzt wir haben einmal
einen neuen xbox one controller und ein
glas gesagt erst gebraucht und
gebrauchten ps4 controller aber der
sieht eigentlich aus wie neu das ding
ist ich würde eigentlich rd nehmen aber
ich glaube viel mehr leute haben die ps4
möchte man nehme ich dann nämlich also
das t shirt gegen eine ps4 kontrolle
danke
das war es eigentlich auch schon ich
weiß nicht also wir würden jetzt hier
weggang als mega folgen naja wider wir
stehen am berufskolleg alles klar
wollen sie wohl noch süßigkeiten
vorher gemacht
[Musik]
leute die waren jetzt die bestimmte
stunde oder so und dann ist das ding
leer
das war ja echt entspannt also schöne
grüße ich habe jetzt einfach schon eine
ps4 controller kommt der sieht aus wie
neu was hast du noch mal angefangen mit
büroklammern büro plan
also fangen jetzt erst mal zurück nach
hause aber ich kann ja jetzt schon mal
sagen ihr könnt gerne weil mir auf
günstigem vorbeischauen da heißt ich
alex wie und mir einfach mal irgendein
produkt schicken was wir gegen den ps4
kontrolle der wirklich eigentlich
brandneu also sind gar keine
gebrauchsspuren dran also wenn irgendwas
zum tauschen dagegen habt dann schreibt
es mir und jetzt geht's nach hause
so leute also leute wir haben jetzt
schon den nächsten tag
ich habe gestern nichts mehr aufgenommen
auf jeden fall haben wir hier den ps4
controller ich finde es wirklichkeit ich
habe jetzt einfach schon eine ps4
controller ich könnte denn eigentlich
sogar selber richtig gut gebrauchen weil
ich ein zu wenig haben können aber das
geht natürlich nicht es geht weiter ich
wollte noch mal ganz kurz mit euch noch
schauen was denn jetzt eigentlich so ein
jahr gebraucht der ps4 kontrolle also
ist ja nicht mehr ganz neu
er sieht allerdings ohne spaß aus wie
komplett rutscht irgendwie ein bisschen
runter
so jetzt bitte stehen so der story auf
jeden fall würde ich sagen er ist zwar
eigentlich nicht neu sieht aber aus wie
neu also wir sind wirklich nur
gebrauchsspuren dran
ich wollte jetzt einfach mal schauen ob
ich auch die richtige entscheidung
getroffen habe ich suche es gerade
einfach mal auf ebay ps4 controller das
t shirt hatte ich einen neuwert von 30
eur 29 490 kostet das jetzt offiziell im
laden und wir haben hier jetzt zwei bis
vier controller im wert von 35 euro ich
glaub neu kosten die ja so um die 50
euro
verwarnung der hier ich weiß nicht ich
würde einfach mal sagen wir hatten einen
wert von 40 euro weil er halt wirklich
komplett gut aussieht die familie hat
mir ja auch noch einen xbox controller
komplett neu angeboten der natürlich
denke ich mir jetzt ein bisschen mehr
wert ist geht sogar eigentlich also auch
so um die 40 euro plus 4 kommt also da
ist eine ps4 controller sogar eigentlich
teurer ich hab den ja aus dem ganz
einfachen grund genommen weil viel mehr
leute eine ps4 haben das heißt wenn er
dinge zahlen wollt schreibt mir für
instagram was ihr dagegen eintauschen
würde so also soviel dazu der tausch für
das heutige video ist jetzt
abgeschlossen werden nicht mehr sehen
würde könnte es gerne abschalten aber
ich habe noch eine frage und zwar wurde
mir auch noch einen mini kühlschrank
angeboten den ich auch gegen das team
hätte tauschen können ich kann euch hier
gerne fotos von dem mini kühlschrank
einblenden und ich war mir unsicher
nehme ich jetzt den oder nehme ich den
ps4 kontrolleur könnt gerne in die
kommentare schreiben was hättet ihr
gemacht würde mich mal interessieren
weil es ist manchmal wirklich sehr
schwer die richtige entscheidung zu
treffen ob ich jetzt das nehmen soll
oder festnehmen sollten auf jeden fall
war es ist dann eigentlich bis hierhin
falls euch das video gefallen hat last
auf jeden fall jetzt schon mal daumen
nach oben da und schreibt in die
kommentare ob ihr noch bockhop auf
weitere parks ich bin auch wirklich
gespannt auf welchem weg ich irgendwann
dann zum iphone komme man muss sagen ich
glaube das potenzial gerade durch euch
dass ich das dann immer zeige welches
produkt habe das ist einfach extrem groß
und keine ahnung ich bin gespannt wie
das ganze leben führt ich habe ultrabook
darauf und es macht mir eine menge spaß
das jetzt einfach mal so durchzuführen
weil das gab es noch nie
und dann sehen wir uns ich hoffe diese
woche schon wieder und mal schauen wer
von euch dann im video
mit dabei ist und irgendwas gegen diesen
ps4 kontrolle eintauscht was eventuell
sogar noch cool also leute das war's von
mir
instagram auf jeden fall ab und ich bin
gespannt auf eure vorschläge
haut rein